good morning everybody happy wednesday
we're starting off with a lot of clouds
out there
and a beautiful shot as the sun tries to
peek through
what little opening is out there on the
eastern horizon we've got 38 degrees
humidity is 68 percent there's still
some moisture out there
and we've got some snow showers taking
shape in the mountains
how do we wind up with rainfall
officially for las vegas
well we almost had two tenths of an inch
some neighborhoods did get more than
that
over the course of the last couple of
days we're about half of where we should
be for the month of january
but we have opportunities to make up for
it with this next big winter storm
that's just pummeling the west coast
pushing heavy rain into central
california right now
and already seeing lots of snow into the
sierras where winter storm warnings
blizzard warnings
are all posted they're going to measure
the snow in feet
and maybe rainfall totals up to a foot
or more too
that is going to be dangerous flooding
expected in parts of california
so here we are with a little bit of snow
in our mountains west valley
neighborhoods where we might have some
near freezing temperatures you might see
a few flakes
mixed in but definitely the chance for
snow remains in the mountains through
the morning hours
a high of 33 with a mix of clouds and
sunshine for us
in the afternoon near 50 today the
better chance for rain comes again
tomorrow night and
showers friday with highs in the 50s
more sun for the weekend
and a little warmer next week